- Today we're going to be learning about earthships,
and I'm so excited to be here.
I'm gonna be living in an earthship,
which is a sustainable home, for 24 hours,
and learning what it really means
to live 100 percent off the grid.
(dramatic violin music)
- Here we are at (mumbles) Earthship,
the place where you'll be staying tonight.
Let's go check it out.
We'll start back here at the master bedroom.
- This room looks so comfortable.
I'm so excited to stay in it.
- [Lauren] Yeah, and Mike Reynolds really wanted
to showcase that you can have all
of the creature comforts that you would normally have,
just living off grid and sustainably.
All of our appliances and lights
are powered by solar panels.
When rain falls, it comes and lands on our roof,
and then it travels down this path,
and goes into this salad bowl,
and it collects in the cistern.
- [Auri] And then that is used for the house?
- [Lauren] Yes, exactly.
We're gonna cool down your space for you.
- [Auri] Cool.
- So we start by opening up this door,
and that has a vent tube that goes
all the way to the back of the building
and is buried in the berm.
- Cool.
- Then, from there, we're gonna open up
your transom windows, which are above the doors,
those have already been opened for you.
- Nice.
- And then, we open up the vent boxes.
- Oh cool! I can feel the breeze.
It just smells so good in here.
I just smell all the herbs, and I know
the air is so fresh, because there's all
these plants here. Mmm, rosemary.
Okay, I'm cold, so I'm gonna try to close this vent here.
- Oh, I got it!
Yay, I got it.
I'm gonna go meet the guy
who designed and built these structures.
- Humanity has six basic needs,
that you can't discount any of them.
It's comfortable shelter, we all need it.
We all need water, we all need electricity.
We all need to do something with our sewage.
We all need to so something with our garbage,
and we all need food.
This vessel, that we call the earthship,
provides these things via encounter
of Earth phenomena, like sun, rain, wind,
to provide sustenance for the person who's in it.
It's all free; it's all here already.
If you have sustenance, then money
becomes paper, which is what it is.
- I'm gonna pick some of these tomatoes
for dinner, with some rice and all that I brought.
This is my dinner that I made with the tomatoes.
I'm excited to eat.
I just feel so good in a space that I know is not
exploiting the environment, but trying to work with it.
You see all these lights? You see all these lights here?
They came from the sun; the power came from the sun.
I'm brushing my teeth with rain water.
I went pee, and now I'm flushing,
and it's gonna go feed the plants.
I'm taking a hot shower powered by the sun
(Laughs)
(mellow chimes play)
Wow, what a beautiful way to wake up.
So, I've decided I want an earthship,
and I want to build one. What should I do?
- [Lauren] Well we have classes that teach you
how to build your own earthship,
and they're about four weeks long,
and we get students from all over the world,
and right here we have Mike Reynolds
teaching students on the job how to build an earthship.
- So, what are all these bottles for?
- So, we build all of our buildings
with recycled materials, and these bottles
are given to us from the dump, or recycling center.
- [Auri] And you also build with tires?
- [Lauren] Yup, tires are the main
structure for the building.
- And why is that?
- [Lauren] We have lots of used tires
that are just discarded and
they support the building really well.
- [Mike] Our relationship of humanity to Earth,
if we're not contributing to this relationship,
if we're only taking from it,
it's just eventually not gonna work anymore,
and it's starting to not work for the humans.
The earth will be fine, the earth will just get
so it can't support humans, and humans will be extinct.
Our dance with this planet is about over.
If we dance in a different way,
if we dance with it, rather than just
taking from it, then we can last a lot longer.
(dramatic violin music)
- [Auri] Bye, beautiful earthship. I'll miss you.